all right so current reads what am i
currently reading
now so here's my current reads i brought
him with me this time
so um a guy named blake bailey one of my
former students mailed me this book the
other day
he was one of my former uh he's students
here at texas tech and
it's a memoir by frederick beekner when
he talks about some
pretty significant trauma he had in his
life i'm rereading this book
adult children of emotionally immature
parents it's such a rock star book by dr
lindsay gibson
and this book is
phenomenal it's called the biology of
desire why addiction is
not a disease it is
wonderful there's a whole a whole bunch
of new literature new scholarship coming
out
about this idea that um addiction is not
a disease we got so excited to call it a
disease for two reasons one
we saw brain change when people like did
cocaine we saw their brain change we got
all excited hey that's a disease
and number two we are so
adamant about putting um
addiction drugs pornography working too
much
as a character issue right if you do
this it's because you're bad
if you do this it's because you're lazy
or stupid that once we were able to call
it a disease then people could finally
get the help they needed
and what this book is coming back and
saying is man
your brain changes all day every day you
get a phone call
you laugh real hard you watch something
that's funny then you watch it again and
you send that clip to your friend and
you watch it again your brain's changing
all the time
and so it brain change is not unique to
using drugs or working too much et
cetera
and man can we all just stop with the
blaming people and lying to people so
it's not a disease
but it does have some addictive
qualities it is not a
permanent brain change yet your brain
does change
part all that goes into itself so dr
mark lewis here
the biology of desire it's a really
great read
and then this man i talked about this i
think in the last ama guys
this is discipline equals free freedom
by jocko
this is the simplest book i've read in a
while and it's really rich and so i'm
doing a daily thing with it where i
read through it again i've read through
it several times and i'm continuing to
read through it and it hasn't
i haven't come across a day yet where
man jocko doesn't say something that
really gets into me and
it may be one of the top three or four
mental health books i've read in 2021
it's really good um and it's simple
right and then
on the fiction front i brought some of
these books man
this book octavia butler's parable of
the talents
if you haven't read this it's really
dark real real real dark
not for your kids it's real violence
real dark
um it is a masterpiece octavia butler is
extraordinary karen russell sleep
donation these are all fiction by the
way
this book was a trip um
i loved it in fact i'd recommend this
book to everybody it's a good book
again all these are really dark dark
fiction um
steven graham jones the only good
indians again this is a horror novel
it's scary pants
and real dark too but it was just a
masterpiece
and then i'm still working through nk
jemisin she is the
i think she's the best science fiction
writer in the world um how long do a
black future month this is just a
collection of short stories
that man i wish my had this kind of
imagination so that's the fiction i've
read
in the last month or two um i've been on
a fiction kick lately that kind of got
burned out on science so i'm just
sticking to a couple of nerd books over
here but
man that's what i'm reading right now i
do again i read a lot i don't have a lot
of friends and so it kind of works out
that way
um what are my favorite fiction books of
all time i actually grabbed them off my
shelf and brought them what's your
favorite fiction book of all time kelly
uh to kill a walking bird oh you would
how noble and whatever of you it's one
that i read probably once a year
i just go back and read it do you talk
do you bring that up at cocktail parties
on like you'd be like
everybody what's your favorite fiction
book mine's to kill a mockingbird
i mean i have others i mean and i read
some pretty like
low brow fiction sometimes but that's
just my favorite that i go back to
like once a year and just reread it just
for the enrichment of your soul
yeah just because i'm better than you
[Laughter]
james what about you um i like the
dystopian
future books like the brave new worlds
in the 1984
listen this is i'm gonna give you this
today butler this is the best dystopian
future novel i've ever read in my life
ever
love it ever let's do it all right good
and then we'll both read to kill a
mockingbird
just to cleanse our souls right so we
can reach kelly's higher plane there
all right so my number one favorite book
of all time is this
danny the champion of the world by raul
dahl he's the guy that wrote
charlie the chocolate factory james the
giant peach he's one of my favorite
authors of all time
this is a book about a dad and a son a
little boy
the little boy's mom passes away and
it's just them too and they go get the
man and it's one of my favorite stories
it makes me cry a hundred percent of the
time i've read it so much throughout my
life it didn't have a back cover i've
got two or three other copies but this
is my og
book um the catcher in the rye actually
carried this book around with me this is
the first time
i ever back in high school right um
chris lowe was the guy was a freshman
he's like hey you got to read this book
and this is the first time i ever read a
book and thought oh gosh somebody's in
my head
and then this book fight club this is
one of the origin this one book was
again one of those books that in my
early 20s i think is when i
found it was like whoa somebody's
reading my mail
and that was a pretty remarkable book
and then
the yearling and where the red friend
grows if you haven't read these two
books stop what you're doing because i'm
about to ruin the image of style you're
used to you've got to read these books
they're so
sad but they're so good those are like
the saddest books ever written
sadder than to kill a mockingbird yes oh
my gosh
yeah i'm the one without a soul ladies
and gentlemen kelly
and um huck finn is awesome jaber crowe
by wendell berry
is awesome um the
harry potter series is great and
to kill a mockingbird that's just not
it's not one of my favorites it's a
great book but it's not one of my
favorites
um yeah those are those books all right
so
what our next question what are the best
books for raising children
okay here's my little rant on this
right now for maybe the last 25 years i
think dobson did this right he kind of
started this in the jesus circles and
then there's been a couple of other
folks
in other circles this obsession with
strategies and scaling and projections
and norming we are so obsessed with
step-by-step plans for
our kids and there are some good plans
out there and some good questions but
i'm more interested in the foundation
stuff because what i found is if you
take care of the foundation stuff
the individual questions answer
themselves a lot
so i'm more interested in helping
parents be whole humans
and helping them deal with their own
crap and then being able to love their
kids and be present with their kids and
be able to be mature adults who love and
model boundaries and good relationships
and then kids turn out fine right if
a parent is well their kids are gonna be
able to handle the world as it comes at
them
right so when p parents ask me hey
what's the best parenting book i always
tell them
books for you and that is my go-to
is i don't want to talk about it by
tyria reel for men
adult children of emotionally mature
parents we talked about that earlier
by lindsay gibson that's for everybody
there's a it's a book it's a written by
a
pastor um i know a bajillion people who
listen this podcast aren't don't have a
faith affiliation but
the book is really remarkable
with or without a faith connotation and
it's called the ruthless elimination of
hurry by john mark comer
it's really really good just as a really
good
introspective look at the way we're
living our lives and then there's a book
finding meaning by david kessler man i
probably
i think i've sold that guy a lot of
books it's just the the book on grief i
got up on my shelf up there
um so many parents don't know how to
grieve and they don't know how to deal
with their past they don't know how to
deal with
this fake picture they had of their
future and they just get stuck on these
loops then they end up just looping back
to their origin stories and they just
recreate it again and again and again
and that book just helps people walk
through
your life is not going to be the
fantasies you had the pictures you had
and you got to deal with them as they
come and man that book's
magic so if you will love and connect
with your kids
find and model joy give your kids
purpose right let them endure struggle
but also show up and give them
boundaries and show them that they
matter
they're resilient they're built like
gumby man they will come back
right and then if you need some very
specific books then you can deal with
those specific things
at that time that's what i tell people
if they asked me for books on raising
kids is that kind of a pass kind of but
i want parents to be okay
parents are not okay they're looking for
strategies to help fix their kids